I was going to say did you have like
because I feel like so not just artists
but specifically artists because you
guys are under a lot of public scrutiny
but
um did you because you're you're so much
more than an artist right and sometimes
fans will just look at you through like
the music lens as opposed to like who
you are as a human being right and I
think a lot of us get so wrapped up in
uh associating our identity
yeah right and there's some people are
like well what are you if your
profession goes away what are you radio
goes away what are you if hip-hop goes
away did you have like a hard time
getting because you had a lot of eyes on
you in terms of like the next up you
know what I'm saying Kanye Coast signs
the Rockefeller [__] you know was there
a point in time where you like kind of
came to like yo I gotta kind of like
remember who I am and separate who Vic
men's is and what who like hip-hop sees
me as and who I am as like a human being
you know what I'm saying I think that's
a constant thing is to recognize that
my identity as a human being and as like
a spiritual being is not same as my
Instagram right right right right right
saying like this thing does not
represent me in totality and I think
that our propensity as people that live
in a public eye can be to place all
weight in that but type of music I'm
making
the art I create that I strive to create
isn't something that's
based on fame or clout or money or right
you know anything like that that's never
been my North Star you know I mean
that's never been why I started to do
this I think oftentimes in today's
hip-hop
especially like
it's a means to an end you know what I
mean people are like man I wanted to do
this because I saw they was rich I
wanted to get rich right you know which
is great but that was never and has
never been my Mo that was never why I
started doing this you know I was
inspired to do this because
the way common talked on record spoke to
me it gave me perspective about myself
you know I mean the way Tupac talked on
record
helped me through
tough [__] you know as a child and as a
man and those are the reasons why I
started to do this so getting in that
position you know to
be there with the people that I idolized
coming into this
um
although that's amazing and that's like
a dream come true
um
that's still not the main reason why I
ever did this but you could get caught
up in that though I mean easy I was
having a convo with no idea the other
day man you know he was like he was like
yeah you you got tossed into the
[__] like the Whirlwind no you
know
Jay-Z Beyonce and the mix of that but
like I said it's like you still got that
magnifying glass on everything that was
there before you know so something I've
been
exploring in this album and speaking
about a lot is the power of my words and
the power of my thoughts you know what
I'm saying and from the time when I was
five years old I found a notebook that
was full of suicidal writings you know
from me that you wrote that I wrote okay
when I was five years old and
um so I kind of always had a certain
programming towards depression and you
know those things will inevitably
if allowed to Fester
come to pass you know so at the same
time as I always wanted to be great you
know I always was feeding this voice in
my head
that wanted to destroy me at the same
time so even though I achieved greatness
I still
had no sense of how
to calm down that innate urge for
self-destruction that was in there you
know so I could be you know on a
tour with Jay-Z you know I mean in front
of thirty thousand people a night and
still be like
depressed you know I mean and not not
living in the moment not living in the
moment not knowing how right and being
like I never even thought it was
possible to impact those thoughts you
know what I'm saying so a lot of the
things I think that people might have
seen you know in the in the behaviors
that were happening simultaneously
um that was just the manifestation of
that other side of my
brain that voice in my head there's I
think a lot of people experienced like
man you don't deserve this you know I
mean you might you're not worth it in
imposter syndrome that's a real thing
you could be really who you think you
are have a voice in your head that you
don't deserve to be for real 100 you
know what I mean and I was experiencing
that [__] constantly so I think in many
ways
I had to
experience the culmination of all of
that and all the controversy and the
drama and you know being ostracized and
outcasted to really get the moment to
reflect and understand like
okay so here I am
I have been blessed immensely in that I
ain't had to die behind this you know
so now let me reapproach this with
intention let me not just let my my mind
say whatever it want to say all day long
and
be beefing with this person and
outwardly expressing whatever
frustration I'm feeling internally right
through all these other things like
because it ain't about that you know
what I mean man about that policeman get
up today
shoot a [__] with his hand in his
hoodie man he probably having a bad day
in his own you know what I mean right
but he's finding
someone else that he might perceive as
being the problem
to express whatever problems he has
going on with himself
do you feel like a lot of your conflicts
were similar in terms of you kind of
dealing with whatever you were going
through by maybe lashing out at certain
individuals or I think it was always
complex you know I think I've been
dealing with a lot since I was a child
identified that I've also been very
politically minded for sure and I've
also stood on what I believe in and the
combination of those
um created a lot of conflicts I mean if
you look back at
all these different conflicts ninety
percent of the time controversies
whatever it is they were rooted in some
principle you know yeah that I felt I
was standing on that most often times if
you were to write it down would be
something that people would agree with
they'd be like yeah but if you just
write down the issue and The Stance the
position I remember I remember very
vividly like when X was alive I kind of
remember why you took the stance you
took and I wasn't mad at it because I
think it was like because of some of the
allegations that he had against him and
I was like I mean I get it you know what
I'm saying but I think in retrospect
obviously
you know not every battle is your battle
and this is what I came to learn really
and what I came to understand is that
like
not all truths need to be told all the
time and the judgment is for God you
know I mean what I don't think I've
recognized and
through that situation was able to learn
was that uh judge not lest ye be judged
condemned not unless you be condemned
you know point of finger you got three
fingers pointing back at you and also
your message is sometimes less important
than your delivery my message was so
often lost in my delivery delivery
because I'm coming from a Brash like
yeah Chicago perspective where I'm like
I don't give a [__] the [__] true yeah
you know what I mean yeah tell me it
ain't true
well you also force people at that point
I feel like there were some certain
points and times where you kind of like
force people to kind of
whether it's fans people to kind of just
choose sides and I understand that's
tough for people you know what I'm
saying and it's also it's also like
eventually
all the bickering and beefing whatever
it's about a lot of a lot of it would
boil down to you see two fools arguing
from a distance you can't tell who was
who right you know what I mean and
if I'm just getting into it with this
person and this person [__] with them
so now they're into it with me and I'm
into it with them right it's like now it
just adds up that people just think
um combative I would come down sometimes
and sit down in the interview and I'd be
me and you know me I'm kind I'm cool I'm
funny I'm nice and people be like man
I'm so surprised how cool you out
thought she was gonna come in here and
try to punch somebody in the face and
I'm like okay I need to change my
behavior because people are
misunderstanding like people are gonna
get whatever they're gonna they're gonna
create the narrative that you know from
whatever information they have that's
out there and not not enough people and
the thing is too headlines that's how
they come up with their narratives they
see the headlines and they're like this
taught me a lot you know people don't
research
there's so much information out there
you know I mean there's so many things
that we're being bombarded with
constantly that it's like people like
going to check sources and see what was
really sad they're seeing a headline
maybe a couple images and they're like
cool okay this person is associated with
that word that action whatever it is you
know move on oh I see it again this
person is now associated with that one I
see it happening so much especially
nowadays it's like it's just crazy like
when it comes to politics when it comes
to artists it's like people just have
their mind made up over whatever blips
they see on their algorithm on IG this
is Snapshot just a headline that's what
that's what most people use to formulate
their opinions and so I think it's like
you know gotta be intentional at this
point in time like
how do I
make all my interactions to the best of
my ability represent me as a human being
in totality right you know what I'm
saying and
how do I stand for the things I believe
in without having to stand against
everyone you know what I mean like
it's not really necessary